you need to understand that everything
you do at the poker table conveys
information
you can't be like all lucy goosey having
a sandwich being on your phone
baby i love it
there's three basic characteristics that
make an elite poker player one is
just a raw skill the other is a
fundamental understanding of the
mathematical side the third part
is what i'd call disagreement in this
master class i'm gonna share things that
i've actually never shared before
for example i look at a guy and say
you've got king knight you're a sick
human
king nine well that's not magic it's
usually based off a combination of
things i'm gonna teach you how to do
[Applause]
[Music]
that
i'm going to teach you tournament
strategy continuation betting picking up
tells
so this towel probably made me the most
money
the classic chip glance tell you notice
that
i see those cards and my brain is
telling my eyes next thing we got to do
is bet chips most of the time it's
totally subconscious
they don't even know they're doing it
poker is an intellectual endeavor
that is totally skill based in the long
run a lot of people can confuse
themselves
into thinking that they're losing
because of luck when it's actually
skilled
one of the absolute best ways to learn
is to go over a hand
in depth in a hand breakdown i bet 11.50
and alec makes it just 2 500.
i still think his range can be
relatively wide now on the river
you're pretty much down to just two
options is this a value bet
or is this a bluff there's no such thing
as a value bluff
okay you just didn't know what you were
doing
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
learning nothing
from those mistakes is the mistake when
you feel like you've got this game
mastered and you've got nothing left to
learn
that's the exact point where everyone
else starts to surpass you
[Music]
i'm daniel grano and this is my master
class
you